what's going on guys this is Rob and
today I wanted to have a discussion
about the Marvel Universe and alternate
realities and things like that because
for casual readers or even those who
don't read Marvel comics but are curious
about how all these different realities
tie in together they can be a very
daunting and somewhat intimidating task
to understand it and so what I've done
is I've created this video in such a way
that I think it will be able to explain
within reason how the concept of
multiple realities exist within the
Marvel Universe so that you can walk
away from this video with a reasonable
understanding of how everything is sort
of intertwined and how everything
affects everything else so if you are
overhearing a conversation or you're
talking to someone and they're talking
about the Marvel Universe what they're
referring to is everything Marvel the
multiverse and the Fantastic Four and
the x-men these are all constructs of
the Marvel Universe and so it's sort of
a misnomer when someone says they're
talking about the Marvel Universe what
they mean is there is the referring to
everything that is Marvel Comics now the
Marvel Universe in and of itself that is
to say the timeline or the continuity
the mainstream continuity is what's
referred to as the earth-616 continuity
this is the main timeline in which
everything branches off of and we'll get
to that here in a second this timeline
dates all the way back to the earliest
incantations of currently existing
Marvel characters so we are talking
about things like timely comics and
Captain America all the way to the
present date whatever data it is that we
choose to use for the sake of this video
I'm going to be using the data for the
Days of Future past simply because the
film is coming out in 2014 and the
timeline or the story of Days of Future
past is very popular among both casual
readers and avid fans of the Marvel
Comics now I'm not going to go into
detail in terms of all the events that
take place in the Days of Future past I
actually have a previous video that I
did on that particular subject and there
should be an annotation on the screen
here in a second what I will do is kind
of go over the importance the important
events that took place because it'll be
very important to us understanding how
it is a timelines work so there was a
point where the Days of Future past was
the main earth-616 continuity in 1980
the assassination of Senator Robert
Kelley and Charles Xavier occurred in
1988 the mutant Control Act was passed
and in 2013 Kitty Prydz mind was sent
back in time to stop the assassination
of Senator Robert Kelley and Charles
Xavier her actions were successful so
the assassination didn't happen and
because the assassination didn't happen
the mutant Control Act was never passed
and because the mutant Control Act was
never passed Kitty Prague's mind should
never have been able to go back in time
to stop the assassination so what we've
run into is a paradox if the
assassination never took place and if
the mutant Control Act has never passed
there should be no reason why Kitty
prods mind is sent into the past in the
first place so the question is how do
you get around this well Marvel invokes
a pretty interesting concept in the
world of space-time and alternate
realities they invoke what's called
branch universe theory what they say is
that because of the fact that Kitty
Pryde went back in time to stop the
assassination of Senator Robert Kelley
she created what's called an alternate
reality this alternate reality still
contains the same events that led to her
traveling back in time in the first
place which is the assassination of
Senator Robert Kelley in 1980 the mutant
Control Act in 1988 and of course her
act of traveling back in time in the
first place
this creates its own new universe but
the most interesting thing about this is
that yes this universe will lead to more
universes and that will lead to more
universes because with this very
circumstance that we have now we've run
into another paradox and as long as this
paradox exists there will be new
universes created because of it now this
concept with a branch universe theory
and the Days of Future past isn't
limited to the Days of Future past this
exists with the age of apocalypse and
other storylines bishops storyline for
example where the actions of Hope
Summers killing 1 million humans leads
to the outcome of his future creates his
own universe which in turn creates more
universes and more universes and this is
pretty much how it works it's the idea
that the mainstream earth-616 continuity
continues on and there are points in
time in the Marvel Universe where an act
is committed that sends the earth-616
continuity down either a very dark path
or a very enlightened path or a path is
really not that different from where it
already is
and then something may happen along that
particular timeline where someone goes
back in time and attempts to change an
event and because an event has changed
it creates a whole new universe with
that being said I hope you guys
understand everything that's going on I
hope it makes sense if it does let me
know and if not I'll try to see if I can
come up with a way to explain it better
thanks for watching guys y'all have a
good one
peace